in boltenhagen in mecklenburg vorpommern
wird direkt an der ostsee kräftig gebaut
hier entsteht ein steak aus holz und
stahl gut zwei kilometer lang die
sogenannte dünen promenade aber dass
projekte gemeinde entwickelt sich zur
problem baustelle
so stehen etwa die fundamente der dlrg
türme für die rettungsschwimmer auf der
völlig falschen seite nicht richtung see
sondern richtung land ich weiß nicht wie
das zustande kommt finde ich unmöglich
die türme von der dlrg dass die zur
seeseite kommen
das erscheint mir völlig logisch warum
die auf die andere seite kamen ich weiß
es nicht für mich die völlige
fehlplanung ihr irgendwas frauen so die
türme müssen auf der seite stehen damit
der weg zum wasser kurz ist genehmigt
werden sie aber auf der landseite
bekloppt jetzt haben die retter einen
viel zu weiten weg deshalb müssen die
schon gebauten fundamente jetzt richtung
mehr versetzt werden
ein paar hundert meter weiter passt es
auch nicht hier ist die neue dünen
promenade 40 zentimeter höher als die
altehrwürdige seebrücke schöner mist da
muss man nochmal ran
obendrein hat man erst jetzt
festgestellt die rettungsschirme
benötigen aus hygienischen gründen eine
trinkwasserversorgung die muss für
teures geld nachträglich verlegt werden
das ist auch in dem was eigentlich nach
so einer langen planung und vor allen
dingen nach dem was das ganze kostet
eigentlich gar nicht passieren da das
ganz typisch wenn so hoch gefördert wird
da leuchten in allen auge dollarzeichen
und der verstand setzt aus ursprünglich
sollte das projekt 6,1 millionen euro
kosten zu 90 prozent gefördert vom land
und der eu nun ist man schon bei knapp
sieben millionen euro tendenz steigend
dazu teilt uns die zuständige
kurverwaltung schriftlich mit ob es bei
der planung und dem bau der dünen
promenade auch zu fehlern gekommen ist
die zur steigerung der kosten führen und
wer dann die verantwortung trägt bedarf
noch der klärung für viele menschen in
boltenhagen
wird es höchste zeit dass das
schnellstens geklärt wird
das muss man vorher planen ich verstehe
natürlich ärgerlich also klar es immer
schade wenn geld unnötig heraus
geschossen wird im kommenden sommer soll
die teure dünen promenade fertig sein
und eingeweiht werden es sei denn es
kommt planungs mäßig wieder was
dazwischen